avec jean-claude ça fait 35 ans qu'on
est ensemble c'est pas évident avance
comprenez sans se parler après on se
parlait sens comprend puis maintenant
comprendre qu'on ne se parle plus on dit
que le sexe aide à supporter le reste
mais nous au niveau du sexe au ya plus d
reste qu à les hommes passé un certain
âge c'est comme les batteries d'iphone
ça tombe d'un coup à plat puis c'est
lors chargé mais pourtant fait des
efforts pour relancer la machine
on essaye de nouvelles positions je lui
gratte le dos il s'endort fait des jeux
érotiques je cache la télécommande il
doit la retrouver au supermarché j'ai
même acheté le geiq durex plaisir
sauvage c'est une pâte rose gluons
translucide sat et chauffe partout tu
létale mais comme jean-claude ivoirien
s'est brossé dans avec nice est en
flammes et des gencives il a gueulé
pendant huit jours
en plus il avait une dent qui tenait pas
bien l affaire d'une danse ça coûte un
bras c'était pas le pied non sinon sur
un site internet coquin on a commandé un
bond où tu te le mettre sur les yeux pis
à démultiplier les sensations érotiques
jean claude a voulu le mettre sur la
bouche pourquoi je me taise non sinon
j'avais vu dans un film ils sont 12 et
le chocolat fondu
ben oui mais moi jean claude à du
cholestérol j'ai pris là fruit d'or pro
activ pour le goût chocolat thé je
saupoudre acte du nesquik sa guise
j'ai l'impression d'être une truffes au
chocolat qui sont une pomme de terre
cuite
non sinon sur un site internet coca on a
commandé une paire de menottes pour
joissains contenu ans de grèce c'est
bien dimanche après midi j'étais attaché
à la tête d'heuliez en porte jarretelles
il allait faire sa petite affaire que
tout d'un coup nous nous serons plus les
clés c'est pas grave on verra ça plus
tard je dis non a dit je fais quoi
j'appelle à surveiller j'ai dit non tu
vois bricorama jeta chalumeau basse et
là on voit que c'est quand même bien que
les magasins sont ouverts le dimanche
mais heureusement c'était une tête de
lit ikea on a plus vite fait de démonter
la tête de lit que faire fondre les
menottes
non sinon j'avais faire un film anglais
vous souhaitez du champagne sur tout le
corps mais jean-claude il me dit et on
vend pas gâcher une bouteille ans
pour ça du coup j'ai pris une canette de
cronenbourg dois je vous ai redit leur
est faite de pavlov mais sitôt qu'il à
respirer l'odeur et la route et sa
troupe et a nommé julien jean claude
darnal g-10 jean-claude il faut que tu
me surprennent g il faut que tu me
surprennent
jeudi déjà on va essayer d'arrêter de se
faire tout le temps des reproches il m'a
dit d'accord mais de quoi on va parler
non je suis content parce qu'il fait des
efforts nous ça va l'amour est dans le
pré parfois y mettre des pétales de rose
sur les libdems à fait pareil bas pour
être surprise j'ai été surpris mais pour
lever les épines temps après il m'a dit
on va regarder un film porno ça va
booster la libido ça m'a déprimé
quand on voit ce qui existe puisqu'on à
moi je suis content qu est-ce que pour
mon anniversaire et m'a fait une belle
surprise il a commandé du viagra en
chine sous emballage il fut créé j'avais
peur que ce soit de la contrefaçon pas
du tout le contraire à trous dose est
incroyable il m'a explosé la tête sur
l'entente de nuit j jean claude un peu
j'ai passé l'âge du marteau piqueur il
n'a été jamais contente quand ça marche
pas tu râles quand ça marche structurale
aussi aller on dire tout haut ce que dit
mon écriture j'en fasse j'y vois là un
des rares l'oreille sinon je sais pas
mais va la passer sous l'eau froide
sinon pense à ta mère 2 heures du matin
je n'avais tellement assez d'être secoué
comme un prunier devant cuisine boire un
verre d'eau je mange une gousse d'ail
je reviens vers jean-claude je fais
toujours au garde à vous ah non mais la
nuit qu'on a passé du fait garni à
volonté non mais il m'a démonter comme
un bloc
[Rires]
non mais le matin pour sortir du lit
j'étais en pièces détachées y avait des
muscats elle pas trahis depuis longtemps
mais il y en avait je savais même pas
qu'ils existaient en plus j'avais les
petits enfants à garder mami a fait de
l'aquabiking donc le répartir les
pilules qui restait j'ai mélangé
discrètement à la pâte et du chat ont la
part du druide ou non mais j'y réfléchis
pour l'instant je reste avec jean-claude
parce que c'est quand même mieux sur
terre qui me connaît le plus et surtout
c'est avec lui que je m'engueule le
mieux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]